problem number one which number has the
greatest absolute value absolute value
is just the distance that the number is
from zero or how large the number is
regardless of its sign or its direction
so if you kind of visualize it on a
number line the absolute value of minus
17 minus 17 is 17 to the left of 0 so
its absolute value is just 17 the
absolute value of minus 13
what's 13 to the left of 0 if you
imagine it on a number line so it's just
going to be 13 absolute value of 15 well
that's just going to be 15 its 15 to the
right of 0 on the number line I think
you see a pattern here when you take the
absolute value of a number you
essentially just disregard the sign the
absolute value of a negative number is
going to be positive and the absolute
value of a positive number is going to
be positive the absolute value is always
going to be positive because you're just
measuring how far you are away from 0 on
the number line and then finally the
absolute value of 19 is going to be
equal to 19 so the number that has the
greatest absolute value well the
greatest absolute value is right there
it's 19 so 19 has the greatest absolute
value so it also happens to be the
largest number here just like that
problem number 2 maybe I'll do this in
gray between which two integers is the
value of the square root of 61 so the
way you think about this is that you
know there's some number that you know
square root of 61 is going to be some
decimal number I don't know what it is
but there's going to be some square that
if I or some number that if I square it
is going to be a little bit lower than
61 and then some other integer if I
square it should be a little bit greater
than 61 so let's see if we can figure
this out so 6 squared is going to be 36
36 and then 7 squared is going to be 49
that numbers not dark enough a darker
color so this isn't going to be the case
right because the square root of 61 or
61 is greater than 49 so the square root
of 61 is going to be greater than the
square root of 49
well actually let me write it this way I
can rewrite six and seven as the square
root of 36 and the square roots of and
the square root of 49 I can rewrite
seven and eight as the square root of 49
and the square root of 64 right I just 7
squared is 49 so the square root of 49
is 7 8 squared is 64 so the square root
of 64 is going to be 8 so I just rewrote
7 and 8 as the square root of 49 and the
square root of 64 well the square root
of 61 is clearly going to be between
these two numbers right it's going to be
between the square root of 49 and the
square root of 64 to 61 is between 49
and 64 so our answer is B square root of
61 is between these two numbers but
these two numbers are the same thing as
7 & 8
next problem number 3 use the addition
problems below to answer the question
all right so they wrote some addition
problems right there we're dealing with
fractions let's see where this goes
based on this pattern what is the sum of
1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 plus 1/16 all the
way to 1 over 1024 all the way to 1024
so let's see what we can we can discern
some type of a pattern here maybe I'll
do this in red just to keep things
interesting so when I when I took the
first two terms so the first when I took
the first two terms I got 3/4 when I
took the next two terms or not the next
two terms when I add another term to it
when I add the one eighth term to this
over here I got seven eight then when I
add a 1/16 to 7/8 I get a 15 over 16 so
the general pattern here is is that
whatever I whenever I add it up my
denominator in my in my sum I guess you
can call it that way my denominator is
going to be the same denominator that I
have right there and then my numerator
if I just look at all of the pet the
pattern here just turns out to be one
less than that right so you know when I
added 1/2 plus 1/4 I got four the Nam
and three in the numerator when I had
1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 8 in the
denominator and one less than that in
the numerator when I added it all the
way to 1/16
I got 16 in the denominator and one less
in the numerator when I added all the
way to 32 I got thirty two in the
denominator and one less in the
numerator and this only worked when I'm
adding successive powers of I guess you
could call it one-half right this is 1/2
1/2 squared 1/2 to the third 1/2 to the
fourth so based on this pattern one is
the sum if I were to go all the way to 1
over 1 over 1024 or 1024 well based on
this pattern my denominator is going to
be 1024 and my numerator is going to be
one less than 1024 so it's going to be
10 23 and that is that is choice C right
there